I'm going with you Anna no things are
looking pretty dark for arendelle Elsa
and it seems like you have a lot of
questions about your magic
apparently all your questions are
related to the threats coming from the
north we know that you will do whatever
it takes to save your kingdom but from
the looks of things it won't be easy
there's a lot going on in the enchanted
forest
we're just glad you have Anna and the
others with you excuse me I climbed the
North Mountain survived a frozen heart
and saved you from my ex-boyfriend fans
have been scouring the frozen to
trailers for any details they can find
do you know the significance of Elsa's
new lizard friend keep watching to find
out what only true fans have noticed so
you know I'm coming
[Music]
Elsa hears a voice in the trailers Elsa
says that she hears a voice I'm who is
calling to you but there might be more
to this voice than just a metaphor
frozen to is inspired by Nordic
countries there is a Nordic folk tale
about a banshee like creature called a
whole drop this is a female figure who
lures people to the forest is this the
voice that Elsa is hearing in the first
trailer there was a mysterious woman we
think this could be the whole draw the
forest people there's another clue that
the whole drah exists the name of the
people living in the forest is the north
old a tribe that name definitely looks
like in North Plus hold report together
these people might be associated with
the whole giraffe
it wouldn't be the first time Disney
pulled from mythology they do it in a
lot of their movies are these forest
people good or bad we're getting a
little suspicious at this point you
don't know what I spent it on a sword
when Elsa and the others part the mist
they enter into the enchanted forest but
no one has been able to enter or leave
for decades no one can
in when I first meet the North Alda
tribe Anna is wielding an interesting
weapon it's a sword and it looks like it
is made of ice did Elsa make it and give
it to her it's not easy to hold
something made of ice it's possible that
this is a hint that Anna might have
powers of her own
either way this sword looks pretty
important the mysterious snowflakes
whatever scary threat passes over
arendelle appears to be mostly wind but
there's obviously something the trailers
aren't showing when storms can be scary
but this one is proof that arendelle
isn't safe the kingdom is not just safe
it's not just wind though when Elsa is
outside the palace a magical force
sweeps over her then mysterious
snowflakes appear in the air like
diamonds at first glance you might think
Elsa made these but she looks totally
taken by surprise the symbols the
symbols on these snowflakes are the same
ones that appear on the giant stones
that mark the entrance of the enchanted
forest
these symbols represents each of the
four elements earth water fire and air
we know that Elsa will encounter spirits
for each element she sees more symbols
in her song into the unknown Gale is the
mysterious woman from the first trailer
and she is a wind spirit how is she
related to Elsa she could be the source
of the threat that's normal baby
reindeer in a split second shot of one
trailer we catch a glimpse of a baby
reindeer this reindeer looks a lot like
Sven's it's possible Sven falls in love
with the dough it could also be a
flashback to when Sven was born but
check out the girl holding the baby is
ice Gale the wind spirit they don't look
like they are in the Enchanted Forest
anymore this baby reindeer definitely
holds some important key to the story
Anna will save the day before Elsa and
the rest of the gang leave arendelle the
head troll talks to Anna in one trailer
we heard him say that they fear Elsa's
powers won't be enough but he also says
without you she may lose herself to it
this is foreshadowing Elsa will be
tempted by all the power in the forest
it will be up to Anna to save her from
herself Elsa's dress in the first frozen
Elsa embraced her icy powers she made
herself a blue dress and did a lot of
scenes she is still wearing blue but she
is also seen wearing red Disney movies
are really big into color symbolism and
read often represents fire why is the
ice queen wearing a fire colored dress
we have a feeling it's more than a
fashion choice this may be a hint that
Elsa can control fire as well the water
horse in the very first teaser trailer
Elsa falls into the sea a scary ice
horse appears and she rides it to safety
this horse has appeared in several more
trailers his name is Ngoc in Nordic
folklore the knockin is a dangerous
shapeshifter who often appears as a
horse or a man it learns people to him
and they become his victims okay we
aren't so sure this Pony is going to be
another friendly Disney horse he sounds
pretty dangerous the salamander in the
most recent trailers Elsa has a
lizard-like friend he's adorable but
he's also really important he's blue and
salamanders dwell in water but
salamanders also symbolize fire and his
name is Bruni which means fire he also
appears to lead Elsa to find the answers
she seeks if Bruni symbolizes water and
fire he could represent the same thing
for Elsa this is yet another clue that
Elsa will be able to control both
elements what things have you noticed
about frozen - let us know your theories
in the comments thanks for watching be
sure to subscribe to the things for more
awesome videos and don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up
we'll see you next time
[Music]